- Oh, hello. Welcome to the video.
Um, what were you doing 90 days ago?
90 days ago, you probably didn't consider
that you would be here today.
You probably figured you'd be alive,
but you probably also didn't consider
what today would feel like.
Maybe you were optimistic
about the future.
Maybe you thought, "Oh, 90 days from now,
I'll live a better life.
I'll do things better."
Or maybe you were just passing
the time doing your thing,
engaging in the day-to-day grind,
and all of a sudden
you just showed up here
and it's today now.
But the weird thing is,
whether you thought about today
or not, you still got here.
It's still today.
Time doesn't care whether you
spent the last 90 days going
to the gym every single day,
packing on like, 25 pounds of lean muscle.
Time also doesn't care
whether you spent the
past 90 days developing
a problematic "Overwatch 2" addiction
and ordering takeout every single day
and not drinking enough water
and getting terrible sleep.
Time's not concerned with any of that.
It'll still just spit you out
on the other end of things
right here, right now.
All of the pain of
overcoming mental resistance
so that you could do things
that are beneficial to you,
and all of the pleasure of
comfort that you engaged in
by playing "Overwatch
2" and eating takeout,
it's all gone now.
It all doesn't matter.
You don't feel that resistance anymore,
and you don't feel the pleasure anymore.
All you have is the result
of those past 90 days.
So what do you have to show for it?
Throughout our lives,
every single day, multiple times a day,
we sort of have these crossroads moments
where our prevailing habit seems
to win out more often than not.
Maybe we're acclimatized
to just pouring hot water
into a ramen packet and watching
TV, and we call that lunch.
And it feels really weird
to actually put some effort
into it, eat something
cleaner and better for us,
so we don't do it because
it feels kind of weird.
But that weird, uncomfortable feeling
that apparently dictates
everything that you do,
it's gone now.
You don't feel that feeling
anymore right here, right now.
And if you just disregarded that feeling
and you did what was good for you anyways,
you would've still arrived
here just the same,
and all you would have is the
result of that good habit.
You would think better,
you would look better,
you would feel better.
And with bad habits,
it doesn't matter how
much pleasure you try
to siphon out of the world.
It doesn't matter how long
or how vigorously you indulge
in whatever your vice of choice is.
The feelings are always just
nullified by time anyways.
You no longer feel the
pleasure of 90 days ago.
All you have is how you
feel and who you are,
and the life you live
right here, right now.
So look around you. Like, how did you do?
How does it feel to be you?
Because everything you were up to
for the past 90 days has been
leading up to this moment.
The life you live was already
decided for you by you.
Now, this might be obvious to everybody.
This is sort of the way the world works.
But I think if we thought
about this more often,
I think we would make better choices.
Because naturally that gets you thinking,
90 days from now, you're
gonna be 90 days older,
and you're gonna feel
exactly how you do now
or much worse or much better.
So even if you feel terrible right now,
I welcome you to embrace this moment.
Some people, we just feel like
passively terrible sometimes.
We don't know why. We just feel trapped.
But it's always a huge
blessing to have clarity,
to realize, "Okay, I contributed to this.
My past 90 days actually meant something,
and I have a role to play
to shape the next 90 days.
And even if I don't want to do
something beneficial for me,
90 days from now, I'm not
gonna feel that pain anyways."
And if I want to go play "Overwatch 2,"
I'm not talking to myself, obviously.
But how cool is it?
It's sort of like a cheat
code when you realize this.
All of the discomfort into
building this better present
that I will be a part of 90 days
from now will be gone by then,
and all I will have is
the result of my effort.
That's an exciting idea.
Here's a really cool visual illustration.
This is a life calendar.
You've probably seen this
in some other YouTube video before.
I find these really cool.
The entirety of this calendar represents
a 90-year life in weeks.
So I'm 26 years old, and
this is my life in weeks.
And this is what 90 days looks like.
It's just such a tiny little blip
in the grand scheme of my life.
It's such a manageable amount of time.
Yet 90 days, as we all know,
is a significant amount of time
to dramatically change things.
You know, three months of diligent work
on building a new habit
or breaking an old one,
whether that's spending time
in the gym or eating healthy,
or just being more proactive at your work,
or spending time with people,
or going for a walk every
day, or drinking more water,
it doesn't really matter.
90 days of doing that new thing
can make your life look a lot different
at the other end of it.
But at the same time, when
you look at this calendar,
you can see that we don't
have an unlimited amount
of 90 days.
We don't have an
unlimited amount of weeks.
Our life here on this Earth is finite.
It matters tremendously that
when we have moments like this,
and we can kind of sober up to the reality
of the fleeting nature of time,
that if we don't like how
we've been spending it
as of late, we can redirect.
Because 90 days from now,
you will be somewhere, God willing.
So why not make that
somewhere you want to be?
I just want to give a big thank you
to Athletic Greens for
sponsoring this video.
You guys have heard me
say it a billion times.
AG1 is by far my favorite
health supplement,
and that's because there is no competing
with its nutritional profile.
It tastes great, i have
it every single day,
and it makes me feel so good.
It is packed with over
75 vitamins, minerals,
whole food-sourced super foods,
and adaptogens in every single scoop.
It ensures that you're
giving your body everything
that it needs to feel focused
and energetic throughout the day.
And why wouldn't you want that?
And since it's sourced from whole foods,
it's extremely bioavailable,
which means that when you drink it,
you don't just urinate it out.
Your body can actually absorb it
and use it in its various faculties.
It's just an extremely high
quality source of nutrition.
So if you wanna join me
in feeling fantastic throughout the day,
then if you use my link
in the description below,
you'll also get a year's supply
of the Vitamin D3 and K2 complex,
which I also have every single morning,
as well as five AG1 travel
packs with your first purchase.
So go ahead and take
advantage of that link below,
and thank you again to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
If you enjoyed this
video and you liked it,
then hit the like button.
Because when you actually
hit the like button,
it shoves my bald head into
other people's homepages,
helping them out, which also helps me out.
So it's just a win-win for everybody
if you hit the like button.
If you're lurking here
and this is the 1,000th time
that you've seen my face,
consider hitting the subscribe button.
Why not?
I like more subscribers.
It gives me a sense of validation,
completely artificially,
which I should not rely upon.
Thanks for watching.